foreign
Rochester Minnesota
at this time and I will not be looking
soon
instruments during the presentation
there are not already FDA approved
objectives for today we're going to
discuss the clinical choices therapy
will benefit patient care
ER
sensitivity genotype test results
let's talk first
in the United States
um
short-term therapy
is the only drug on the market today
that is the only Factor 10 inhibitor
available today
uh register editing news only
connect
Ed
ask that question please go ahead and do
so and I will respond there are
questions that are collected for the
presentation at the end of my
presentation
all right let's go back to uh the
presentation let's talk about the pros
and cons of
currently available
um
anti-coagulation agents
as I mentioned is IDE with the fast
actor uh
entirely and the test for aptt team is
commonly used to monitor the
effectiveness of that
it's disadvantages or that is
for short periods of time it's only used
for shut anticoagulation
situation is nothing the topic of our
discussion today uh the advantages there
is a large clinical experience
uh and the test called IR is used to
monitor
uh the disabilities that is it has
several standards events uh these are
well known
um as I would talk to my physician
calling some viewers
uh working
extensively uh those tuning that they
thought I put them but at the same time
it's a very effective drug and that's
why they use it
the disadvantages is not approved for
Orthopedic gas and there is no reversal
agent so if a patient for the doses on
Clopidogrel is not intervention or no uh
antidote to reverse the Rhythm that
might occur
there's no reversal agent
rather
is not required
disadvantage limited clinical experience
in the reversal agent Polo rabaroxaban
is starting to become a significant
um
the clinical experience with that drug
is growing very rapidly
yeah
advantages
the disadvantages it's not a point for
us patience and there is no reversal
agent
our natural man is
there is one of the many of the
advantages uh disadvantages
and there is no reversal agent so around
these agents Insurance extensively
working has changed excessively uh by
the oxidative is starting to become
quite large across the United States so
I'm going to focus on those issues as we
go through this presentation
foreign
patients with atrial fibrillation it's
used for approval accessibility
in patients with prosthetic heart valves
and myocardial infarction
and it's used for prevention of
pulmonary embolism
thrombosis in patients undergoing
surgery or another history of Venus or
arterial Ensemble embolism
foreign
each year in the U.S
the answers
uh I started out more from which year
was the standard practice today to
manage corporate therapy so the
neurologist Heparin first
communities aptt to manager then you
start on five milligrams per day
uh
with the optimal range to the 3.5
or the menu monitor ESR and you want it
to be greater than 10.
what's the standard practice today for
managing Warfare
high probability that you're not going
to have excessive bleeding
think about that question
starts
changed in the first three months of
therapy presidential nuclear
once or twice
three to five times six to three times
organizers 10 times
average 25 times
is not going to occur is rare and there
are some patients that require up to 10
different dose changes to reach a steady
state
Premiere in the U.S
true
the cost of more Finance is
buried in 20 billion dollars per year
uh in the U.S
and but science here in front of our
pleasure to change my audio settings a
little bit let me look at this here just
test your audience is lower your mic all
right
hope that's a little bit better
so
20 million prescriptions for war from
written every year
and the cost of Warfarin Adverse Events
uh more than two billion dollars per
year in the United States very
significant cost associated with
Warfarin use
however as I mentioned earlier
my physician College told me that
working is a good drug they use it but
they fear it because of the Adverse
Events associated with it
so what's the average cost of
hospitalization for a major warfarin
induced bleed
the photograph on this slide is of a
minor bleed that's not a lead sufficient
to suggest
hospitalization so we're talking worse
than what is shown here what's the cost
of hospitalization due to work for
induced sleep
on average it's 36 000 so uh if you have
to put a patient in the hospital the
cost is quite significant
so here's the Warfare molecule it's a
chromium derivative
it has an isomeric carbon in it so it
has an r and s isomer you can see the HS
and HR let's flip to the next slide it
starts to become a little bit more clear
this Warfarin is the active form of the
drug it's approximately five times more
active than our Warfarin so the majority
of the focus of this presentation going
forward is going to be on the S4 for an
isomer
that's considered Warfarin metabolism
for just a moment
yes isomer of Warfarin is metabolized by
cytochrome
p452c9 it's metabolized two seven and
six hydroxy Warfarin metabolites that
are inactive
the r Warfarin isomer is metabolized by
different enzymes cytochrome p450 182
304 and 2c19 to the
four seven and six hydroxy Warfarin and
those are inactive
the rate of metabolism of our Warfarin
is approximately three times slower
and then the metabolism of this worker
so there is a difference in terms of how
the isomers are metabolized
we're going to focus on cytochrome
p452c19 has the major enzyme associated
with significant report from metabolism
through the remainder of this talk
if we consider the mechanism of action
of Warfarin we really want to focus on
the coagulation Cascade if you take your
eye down to the low part of the image
what we're interested in is the
activations of factors
2 7 9 and 10 through the coagulation
Cascade
regulation Cascade involves an enzyme
called vitamin K epox epoxide reductase
that converts vitamin K to the reduced
form
uh and then that Cycles in as a cofactor
to gamma glutamyl carboxylase and
Calumet
factor to act
ORS in that cycle then Vitamin K is
regenerated and it continues through
this through process so we're really
interested in
uh converting inactive factors to 7 9
and 10. to the active factors to induce
clotting
Warfarin essentially inhibits vitamin K
epoxide reductase so you do not convert
vitamin K to the reduced form so factors
2 7 9 and 10 remain in their inactive
form
and coagulation is not taking place
so if we look at this entire picture
we're fundamentally interested in the
metabolism of Warfarin so if you have
Active Metabolism you eliminate Warfarin
and reduce the antichristic coagulation
effect and we're interested in this
enzyme vitamin K epoxide reductase
uh in the presence of Warfarin that
enzyme is the two
not
convert inactive to active factors
so coagulation does not occur
so now we're going to focus on the genes
involved if we think about it in the
context of pharmacokinetics
uh cytochrome p452c9
uh actively metabolizes and warfarin and
if there are polymorphisms in the gene
coding for
sip2c9 uh there's decreased metabolism
of Warfarin if you think about the
pharmacodynamics or the mechanism of
action vitamin K epoxide reductase
complex one often abbreviated as
dkorc1
the important
polymorphisms are in the promoter region
that decreases the amount of synthesis
of dkorc1 resulting in decreased vitamin
K regeneration
the three Snips that are considered to
be of most importance in clinical
practice are identified in this slide
the star tune
snip is a conversion at the 430 position
of C to T that's a protein change of
arginine to a cysteine at the 144
position
when that
entire conversion occurs there's about a
17 decrease
in the enzymatic activity
uh the star three uh
snip is a conversion of a to c at the
1075 Gene position which converts an
isolucine to leucine
and there's about a 37 decrease in the
enzymatic activity per allegiate change
and there's a star six uh it's a bit
more rare than the star 2 and star 3
which is a deletion of adenine and
818 results in a complication and
there's zero percent activity per allele
um in the event that that snip is
present
there are other alleles reported uh with
respect to warfarin there's too little
evidence to understand how you would use
that information in clinical practice
so today in clinical practice the focus
is on the star two star three and star
six
uh allele
variances
vitamin K epoxide reductase the key
enzyme is
the
guanines have any polymorphism at
position 1639 in the promoter region
which reduces transcription of vitamin K
epoxide reductase there are other Snips
as you can see them on this particular
Slide the good news is that the G to a
polymorphism at 1639 is highly
associated with the other
known Snips so if you monitor
1639 uh snip you get pretty much
it's a dominant piece of information out
of the genotyping that will help you
understand whether vitamin K epoxide
reductase is affected or not
so the key terms to remember is set to
C9
if you have a homicidal one star one
that individual is a rapid metabolizer
and in fact the rapid metabolizers will
may require a higher dose of warfarin to
achieve significant Panic regulation so
if you have a patient with star one scar
one
if they don't receive a higher dose
their INR is going to be too low and
that does predispose them to to stroke
star one star two is the dominant uh or
what you'd call Wild type
they're also considered to be rapid
metabolizer and they get the usual dose
of five milligrams a day for an adult of
average weight in age
star one star three has reduced
metabolism slightly lower dose of
Warfarin is required star two star two
has poor metabolism and even lower dose
and a star two star three heterozygous
individual is a very poor metabolizer
and they will need a much slower dose of
warfarin to achieve optimal in-tech
regulation
we consider the vitamin k-poxide
reductase
the GG
wild type
produces
the amount of protein that the typical
Warfarin doses adjusted for
uh if they have the ga snip
they're producing less protein and so
they will require a moderate dose
reduction and if they have the AAA
homozygous
polymorphism they will make even less
protein
that requires an even lower orphan dose
this was our learning experience at Mayo
Clinic and it it really helped aim in my
physician colleagues understand how best
to use war from genotyping if you focus
on the left side of the slide the common
wild type 2c9 star one star one and uh
let's move over to the next one 2c9 star
one star two those are the most common
types with the vitamin K oxide in the GG
phenotype or genotype
of these patients typically respond well
to the typical Warfarin dose of
approximately five milligrams per day
for an average adult average weight
average aging As you move your eye to
the right of this slide you will see
that the more we
experienced
nucleotide polymorphisms the lower the
dose has to be to achieve optimal
response to Warfarin and if you focus on
the
far right
step 2c9 star 2 Star 3 vitamin k a a
that's the most sensitive
Warfarin genotype those patients
actually require about a 60 to 80
percent dose reduction to achieve
optimal anticoagulation
so this was our learning set
we published this in Mayo Clinic
proceedings in 2009
if we just focus in on
homogene or variants did we see among
the different genotypes or if we looked
at the first 10 weeks of therapy
considering that the optimal INR was two
to three you can see that the patients
with the normal
genotype start one scar one GG Type X
had a pretty typical experience of what
you optimally want with Warfarin but as
you get into the patients with the
genotype that represents more and more
polymorphism
they showed a lot more INR variants on
average and more importantly if we go to
this slide this is the highest INR
experienced during the 10-week cycle
you'll notice that in the first few
weeks
some of these experience these patients
experience very large transient ionized
during the first few weeks that required
a significant dose
reduction to achieve optimal response so
the patients with the
very sensitive polymorphisms
that would be star two or Star 3 and GA
or AA type you can expect those patients
who will have much larger variation in
INR early in their dose cycle
well let's uh put a question to you what
is the most sensitive war from
genotype is it a star one star one GG
is it a star one star one GA a star two
star one GG the star two star three GG
or a star two star three AAA
what's the correct answer
I hope somebody in the audience
just saying wait a minute that's wrong
because indeed it is wrong five is the
correct answer the most sensitive
Warfarin genotype is sip two c nine star
two star three AAA
uh if you ever see a patient with a star
to restart three they're even more
sensitive but the frequency of that
particular genotype is is very rare
now I'd like to transition to a more
recent study
an outcome study that evaluated the
clinical utility of warfarin genotyping
uh this was a large prospective
Nationwide study to evaluate the
effectiveness of Warfarin genotyping
the target
patient was a community outpatient
practice
uh their work comparative groups and
intervention group with Warfarin
genotyping and a control group with no
war from genotyping
and the outcome was evaluated based on
hospitalization rates based on the
differentiating between all cause
hospitalization or hospitalization due
to the horizontal embolism and the ICD-9
codes were used as the primary
indicators
this study was carried out between large
medical centers and a large insurance
company who had access to a number of
these bits of information
study was published by Epstein and the
general American College of Cardiology
in 2010.
um
so the way this study worked was that
because it was run in collaboration
between several medical centers and a
large insurance provider
car we were able to interact with
pharmacies across the entire United
States
so when a physician
ordered a new work and prescription and
the patient showed up at the pharmacy
the pharmacy would initiate contact with
the patient and the study
so if when the study contacted the
patient and if the patient agreed to
participate then the study contacted the
provider and if the provider was willing
to participate the study moved forward
and a home health care nurse visited the
patient at home to obtain IRB informed
consent
to obtain a history and including the
reasons for Warfarin and cool
medications and to collect the blood or
a buccal sample
once the sample was collected it was
sent to the laboratory where genotyping
was performed the report was then faxed
to the provider and the laboratory
report included recommendations for
dosing the recommendations essentially
were
increased dose to to maintain therapy
again in our patients likely to respond
to usual dose modest decreased dose
recommended to maintain therapeutic INR
for a significant decreased dose to
maintain therapeutic INR uh and more
frequent eye in our monitoring
recommended
and then in a few cases where we had
these very high genome types and there
were 36 patients in this particular
study with the very very sensitive
genotypes a phone call to the provider
alerted to the fact that this patient
for me uh be very susceptible to
warfarin
for inclusion in this study
um
the patients had to be on Warframe for
at least three months and their patients
had to be in the range age range of 40
to 75 the patients were followed for six
months
and a complete patient medical care
utilization must be available so to
start with we enrolled 1600 patients and
by the time the study was completed 896
patients qualified for inclusion so we
have six months of follow-up
uh and all the medical information was
available for evaluation
patients came from across the entire
United States
including Alaska and Hawaii
there's a concern about studies like
this it's called the study effect that
means if you intervene with the patient
the patient is going to be more
responsive to therapy
and you have to design the study so you
avoid that
criteria defined to anonymize the study
effect is to have minimal interaction
with the participants
it's ideal to have a high recruitment
rate
uh one uses a quasi-experimental
statistical design with propensity
scores identified to compare the
different groups
in this particular study the recruitment
rate was 65 and that was considered to
be a very high recruitment rate for a
study like this so the belief was that
the study effect had minimal effect on
the outcome
the
genotype distribution observed in this
particular study was Heavy books your
attention on the prevalence note that
he
Warframe sensitivity identified as being
very high sensitivity that would be the
VK AAA or GA type and the sip2c9 star 3
or Star 2 type
represented two and a half percent of
the patients
our clinical recommendations with these
patients received significantly
decreased Warfarin dose and frequent INR
monitoring
those with high Warfarin sensitivity
that would be AAA and star one star two
type four percent
those with moderate sensitivity uh star
one star ones and so forth uh 25
of the population
those with what we've defined as mid
Warfarin sensitivity they were all of
the bkg type with uh 2ci and star one or
star two twelve percent
the normal genotype which is GA and star
one star one 29 of the population
and actually less than normal Warfarin
sensitivity GG star one star one
genotype 25 of the population
we point out to you is that a
significant fraction of this population
was of the less than normal Warfarin
sensitivity
star one star one type these patients
require a higher Warfarin dose
um this was a surprising outcome of this
particular study because this fraction
of the population in this particular
genotype group was higher than reported
by others
the study involved intervention groups
and historical controls as well as
external concurrent control so we
basically controlled for changing
practice from the year before to the
year of the study and we monitored
patients who were received Warfarin
genotype information and prepared them
against patients who have not received
I'm going to flip through this fairly
quickly
some of the spring for hospitalization
for any cause
so if you consider patients who are
started on warfarin
within the first six months
of therapy on average at the end of that
narration 23 percent of them had a
hospitalization experience
for those patients that were treated
with genotyping 15 of them had a
hospitalization
strength so now we're talking to any
cause
obviously patients who are going on
Warfarin are sick patients
so there's a variety of reasons why they
would go in the hospital but certainly
from the standpoint of management the
patients who were treated with Warfarin
genotyping
had a lower hospitalization rate by a
factor of about 35 percent let's say a
hazardous ratio of 0.67
if we consider hospitalization rates
only for bleed or thrombol embolism
at the end of six months the patients
who were treated with outdoor from
genotyping
six percent hospitalization rates so six
percent of the patients ended up in the
hospital that number is consistent with
many other reports
for the hospital's implementation rate
for patient center Warframe
for those patients that were
treated with Warfarin sensitivity
genotype
the hospital organization rate was or in
the ballpark of three percent so there
was about a 50 reduction in
hospitalization rate
before bleed or tromble embolism
based on whether a patient was treated
with or without foreign genotyping so a
fairly significant hazards ratio we have
about twice the hazard of becoming
hospitalized hospitalized
during the first six months following
the warfarin therapy if you're treated
without fluorophy genotyping
the key findings patient security report
from sensitivity genotype experience 35
reduction in all cause hospitalization
43 reduction in major bleed or stroke
and surprising to the steady
was that the impact was greater on the
incidence of stroke
and attributes that to the fact that the
number of patients that had the less
than normal sensitivity to warfarin that
25 who needed a higher dose
um
that particular group was significantly
impacted
if we consider the national U.S cost
impact over the six-month monitoring
period all cause patient costs uh was
over
4127 for those that were genotyped
versus five thousand forty dollars for
non-genotype controls that includes
and estimated cost of 300 for the
genotyping so that that was factored
into that cost
so the patients who were genotyped
had an average saving of about 253
dollars per patient
if we were to translate that to two or
one patients
started on working annually in the U.S
and work on sensitivity genotyping were
implemented that would decrease the cost
of Care by a half a billion dollars in
the United States
let me come back and re-emphasize that
if a Warfarin sensitivity to genotyping
were implemented across the board the
cost decreased to the entire U.S
population would be in the ballpark of a
half a billion dollars
now let's translate these findings to
practice
one of the early studies that started to
demonstrate the value of Orphan
genotyping was carried out in Israel in
this particular case they demonstrated
that
when patients were managed with the
genotype information the time to study
State INR decreased by 50 so the time
the steady state
INR for patients managed for genotyping
it occurred in five to seven days
whereas those that were managed without
genotyping the average time to stable
INR was in the ballpark of 10 to 15 days
and if you're putting a patient on
Warframe you're putting them on Orphan
to avoid formation of clots that will
lead to a stroke
if you can get them to stable INR fast
there is a benefit
Hazard ratio here was almost three to
one so the benefit
to those patients that were genotyped
and treated appropriately uh was a
threefold benefit in
in
regions steady state INR
I've caught your attention to work done
by Dr Brian Gage at Washington
University Dr cage has created a very
nice website that is available online
for those of you who are interested in
this topic that encourage you to visit
that website
www.warferndosing.org Dr page offers a
uh if you enter patient demographics
that includes a lot of information about
important things like race age uh
smoking status whether the patients are
on amiodarone whether they're on a
Statin on this particular website will
project
the optimal girlfriend goes for that
patient
so let's come back and talk about
incidents what is the incidence of
warfare insensitivity the less sensitive
genotypes approximately 25 of the
patient population they need a higher
Warfarin dose the typical
orphan sensitivity genotype that's the
star one star one V8 29 of the
population they will respond very well
to the typical Warframe
dose mild sensitivities 12 percent
and we get down the very sensitive and
extreme sensitivity foreign
2.6 point out here that the
uh 33 percent of the population
requires a lower Forefront dose
point out particularly that the less
sensitive 2c9 star one star one GG
genotype is very common among those of
African origin and that might explain
why more
patients of African
origin have stroke on Warfarin than
compared to caucasians Asians on the
other hand have the
2c9 star one star one
dkaa type more common than in caucasians
the extremely sensitive genotype two and
a half percent of the population that
means two
to three patients out of a hundred
started on Warfarin are going to require
a very very low dose don't you think it
would be advantageous to know that
before you start
managing this patient rather than 10
weeks afterwards
come back to the Mayo experience I
showed you the slide earlier and I'm
going to move on now to the FDA warning
relatable that occurred in February 2010
you can flip back and forth between
these two slides
uh they are virtually identical so the
recommendations for dosing
put out by the FDA in 2010 are
essentially identical to the experience
that we had
uh yep nail
lab recommendations with regard to what
to do with the specific genotypes if you
have the less sensitive
uh
genotype it is based on the usual dose
adjusted for age weight and cold
medications add 20 to that dose a
typical genotype the star one
star one GA receives the usual dose
star one star two GG type about a 10
dose reduction
the various step 2c9
variants with various VK variants 30
dose production as we get down into the
very sensitive genotypes
up to 60 dose reduction in the
recommendation that much more frequent
high in our monitoring is indicated
foreign
make a note to the producer of this for
just a second tracing my phone just uh
went offline hope you can still hear me
um let's talk about benefit to practice
so in a typical practice the provider
would write a prescription the patient
provides uh
uh Buckle sample and a Warfarin first
dose administered that evening typically
you would give the patient the usual
dose if it's an adult of average size
and age five milligrams per day
the work from genotype results comes
back the next day and then a dose
adjustment is made if needed
under this type of practice condition
our patients achieve stable dose in INR
faster they require fewer of those
changes and have fewer INR outliers
those are significant benefits to the
practice
patient benefit well the patient
experiences fewer Adverse Events
the patient requires fewer dose changes
in the patient has a bit less expense if
we consider the average prescription
cost to a patient it's not the total
cost this is the cost of the patient or
Warfarin is approximately nine dollars a
month for products is 200 a month for
Xarelto it's 250 a month on average
so the out-of-pocket extends to the
patient
is significantly less
by Warframe prescription Guided by
uh Warfarin genotype
evaluation
a couple cautions it's interesting how
our government operates the Food and
Drug Administration recommends but does
not require orphan sensitivity
genotyping
the center for Medicare services will
not reimburse for Waterfront sensitivity
genotyping
the American College of chest physician
guidelines published in 2009 explicitly
did not recommend Warfarin sensitive
genotyping
however those guidelines that were
updated in 2012 explain Warfarin
sensitivity genotyping the do not make
recommendations regarding their use
so at this stage in in the
sequence of events
work and sensitivity genotyping is not
considered to be the standard of
practice
uh if you have a patient who is on
Medicare CMS will not reimburse for the
testing so the patient will experience
about a 300 charge
and yet the FDA recommends for
insensitivity genotyping
a bit of a conundrum and I'll leave you
to decide what's the best thing to do
for your specific patients
Let's uh in this with a short quiz again
what's the standard of practice today to
manage Warfarin therapy
I hope you all got this right two to
three INR
which is the most sensitive Warfare
genotype
except 2c9 star 2 Star 3 bkaa if you
ever saw a patient with 2c9 star 3 star
3D vkaa that patient would even more
sensitive but the incidence of that is
about one in ten thousand or so
what is the benefit to practice
will providers know which patients will
require more management than typical
with experienced World providers know
which patients will require less
management
will patients achieve stable dose and
INR faster with fewer dose changes in
our INR outliers
will patients experience fewer Adverse
Events
for all of the above what is the correct
answer
well all of the above should be expected
at this point I will turn to ask if
there are any questions I don't see my q
a button flashing so so far there
haven't been any questions submitted
um I'll thank you for your interest
and direct you to uh website so in order
to obtain a continuing education credits
go to
www.bioconferencelive.com CME Dash CE
um I still don't see any questions
showing up so there is a chat room
and I will be available on the chat room
for a short period of time if any of you
have any individual questions you'd like
to ask I will be at the chat room so I
thank you for your attention and wish
you a good day thank you
foreign
and I have a first uh question
so uh
Emilio's from the University of General
Ross says the trial showed a major
impact on stroke the supplies that it's
a matter of resistance rather than
sensitivity
uh
anecdotal
anecdotals
I had the impression that we have sort
of reluctance to increase dosage of
Warfarin did you
well in the answer to that question the
uh
it's not an issue of resistance it's
that the metabolism
of Warfarin occurs
faster than normal
can the amount of protein
the bkorc1 available to activate
clotting factors
is increased So the patient's need a
larger dose of warfarin to maintain
optimal
um
anticoagulation would you call that
resistance I don't think that's
resistance it just means that
pharmacokinetically and
pharmacodynamically the patient's
are more
effective coagulators so you need more
warfarin to
achieve optimal anticoagulation
there's your second question here what
is meant by recruitment rate
so where Chris and Raiders if you
approach a patient and ask if they will
be involved in the study
and they decline
um but they're not involved in the study
so if you ask sixteen hundred people
foreign
of them say yes I will be involved in
the study that's a recruitment rate of
approximately 65 percent
so recruitment is important in the sense
that the patients uh
are willing to participate and in this
particular study the patients have to be
willing to participate and the
Physicians had to be willing to
participate so it took two individuals
to
achieve a recruitment into the study
High recruitment rate is considered to
be better because statistically it means
that your your data are going to be uh
more representative of the entire
population
so Tracy I'm not seeing any more
questions so let's end the broadcast
thank you all very much